can you talk about that year that you
were sort of in this rut for maybe day
one today 360 for each day did something
new to happen did you see someone that
said who I like this person's
interesting i want to write about well
for us that year was comprised of
working with other people on other on
their projects true and so it was kind
of building on our community a little
bit so we weren't completely not doing
anything but we just we just got in
through the rudd of helping others
complete their projects and we forgot oh
some of them are great i mean like
so connect to wonders previous short
film that played a danceable films last
year was a part of that we edited that
yo and then i produce ten chris edited
ifp spotlight winner photo booths which
was shot up 35 millimeter films forget
to work on the 35 millimeter editing
process and producing process so yeah so
there was that and i think i think we
just then finally said you know we need
to get back in the director's seed
because we were watching all these were
like something's missing out of all
these projects oh they're not ours you
know kind of thing and so we were just
like inspired to just like we need it we
need to do it again we need to make
another feature because we were working
on a lot of things that were shorts too
which is great but just like you know
we've already made a feature we can do
this again why aren't we yeah moving
towards making another feature so I like
you I can't pinpoint if there was a
specific moment of inspiration or
anything
we got the bug and then we went yeah
we're bored yeah we just couldn't I
don't know what we like just sat down
for a weekend and hammered out and
outline and then and then spent the next
you know nine months or something right
I think it was the Sundance writing
deadline was what really spurred us Oh
miss Mia we submitted last vacation to
that I think yes bird us to get okay
well regardless of you get into anything
deadlines are awesome yeah that's holy I
was the Sundance that producers lab
directors lab that we were submitting
our script 20 or so writers the right
which is the writer's life yeah yeah
because that's how you get to the
director yeah but you know I mean it's
always in its a shot in the dark but the
deadlines there so it'll at least make
you finish something exactly there's not
a deadline there were you know we runs a
ver terriers is on netflix now so it
said you can ever be anything what what
gifts do you each bring to your team you
know what David myself we have our
pluses and minuses was really
maybe needs more work yeah for the two
of you I'm a control freak so that's my
plus I've embrace it no it really helps
me and produce see scheduling all the
logistical issues I project management
comes really easy to me and so an i do
it a lot in my job as well at my day job
and so i tend to in pre-production takes
the weed we say 7030 split so i'm a
seventy percent in pre-production and
chris is helping but just in a and
that's slightly more support you usually
by saying things like I want a
helicopter and then running away and
then make her figure in writing we're
definitely fifty-fifty we definitely
have strengths Chris he can his rough
draft is always perfectly formatted and
exactly the way a script should look and
read and feel and everything else in
mind like the user this jumbled mess and
it's just like I'm giving you exactly
the exact thoughts that I think people
should say I'm not going to be around it
at all you know so my my scripts are
very lean his are very wordy and so we
kind of then balance each other out
because I'm trimming and he's a team and
you know that sort of thing and then I'm
on set where you know Chris tends to be
he works a little bit more with the DP
in the camera Department that's because
his head were still in he's an editor so
he tends to illinois i think i can see
the pieces of the movie I think clearer
probably than you can but you can see
the emotional through lines yes maybe
not clear but like you just you have a
different way poaching it then yeah I
tend to be more intuitive that way and
then I'm also working with 80 in the the
production side of
that way and then in post chris is an
editor so he tends to take a little bit
more the lead in the 7030 split where's
like it's just it's nice as I get to
really just sit back and and well it was
it was really it was good on this is our
so it was the first time that I was
working with someone else as a co-editor
which was a phenomenal experience and i
highly recommend all directors who added
their own things get another ready but
we since she and i were working on it so
closely we can actually reserved Lindy
so that she would only watch scenes that
we thought we'd done so that she never
had to go through the process of seeing
rough cuts and whatever so that when she
was seeing a scene it was fresh and she
could give her like it was it was it was
a new perspective was coming into the
process because we could just let her be
away from it yeah yeah which is really
helpful
you